Mark Russinovich: Good
afternoon, everybody.
Ion Stoica:
Good afternoon.
[ Applause ]
Mark Russinovich: So it's good
to see you all here at Build.
I'm Mark Russinovich.
Ion Stoica:
And I am Ion Stoica.
Mark Russinovich:
And we've got kind
of a fireside chat today,
but it's a fireside chat
where we don't have a moderator.
We're moderating ourselves.
So, we're going to be
talking through a bunch
of questions related to AI,
AI infrastructure, models,
architectures for AI,
and it should be a pretty
engaging conversation.
Ion Stoica: I hope so.
Mark Russinovich:
Yeah. So,
I think we can start
by talking a little bit
of our background and why we're
up here talking about
these subjects.
So, Ion, you've got a background
where you've had some amazing
impact on the industry
in data analytics, in AI, in
your role as a professor,
in your role as a
startup founder, Ray,
vLLM, Databricks, Spark.
Why don't you tell us a little
bit about your background?
Ion Stoica: Yeah, so actually,
starting around 15
years ago, at Berkeley,
we started to develop
a little bit more,
quite a bit of systems, a few
systems, initially in the space
of domain of big data.
And started initially
with Mesos and Spark.
Then after that, Ray, and more
recently, vLLM and Golang.
And I think, as a high
level, we're always looking
about, obviously, trying to
understand and to figure
out what is a problem
you try to solve;
and also, a little bit
careful about the trends.
What I mean by that, a
problem you have today,
is that problem going to be
bigger tomorrow than today?
And, you know like,
things like, obviously, Spark
was scaling up data analytics
and making more interactive,
and much better support
iterative kind of patterns
like machine learning,
then Ray, complex scaling,
complex AI workloads
like reinforcement learning
on heterogeneous
hardware back then.
And, of course, vLLM is
to us is clear that trying
to exploit the power limits
inherent of the GPUs.
But then the memory became--
it was a bottleneck.
So, trying to alleviate that
bottleneck and things like that.
The one thing I want
to say, because we are
at the Microsoft conference
here, is that I'm very happy
that, actually, some of the
things we've done has impact also
with our kind of collaboration
and partnerships.
As you know, Spark and
kind of Databricks, great,
fantastic partnerships
with Azure Databricks.
And actually, today, we also
announced a partnership
between Azure and Anyscale,
and Anyscale is around Ray.
So, yes, very happy about that
and very much looking forward
to this partnership to grow.
Mark Russinovich:
Likewise, yeah.
It's been an awesome
partnership.
Ion Stoica: Yeah.
So, you know,
on my side, you know, you
you Mark, you have so much
contributions, you know.
You ship CC internals, then--
Mark Russinovich: Have you
ever used these internals, Ion?
I'm putting him on the spot.
How many people have used it?
Ion Stoica: But you
architected Azure
infrastructures,
which I did use.
And then you are now building
and architecting AI
infrastructure for Azure,
and security are leading.
So, one question I have, you've
seen all these kind of phases,
and you've been in
distributed systems
for a long time and security.
So, what is new and what is old?
What still applies and why
is no longer applying?
Mark Russinovich: Yeah, well,
that's a good question.
I think one of the things that
still holds, and this holds,
I think, you'll even say for
infrastructure and systems,
is the fundamentals
are still in place.
I think if you take a look at
fundamentally what's changed,
it's these non-deterministic
systems that are now
carrying out workflows
that they create on the fly.
And that introduces a bunch of
new risk area. You know, we --
In some sense, humans are
non-deterministic agents
creating workflows on the fly.
But humans you can
hold accountable.
Also, humans, I think in
general, are more reliable
than the AI systems we
have today, and certainly,
when it comes to humans,
we designed our systems
around human speed and scale.
And when you have agents now
that are intelligent running
around, they can perform lots
of damage in a very
short period of time.
So I think if we get into
it a little bit later,
we'll talk about
some of the things
like prompt injection
risks around that,
risks around jailbreaking,
risks around hallucination;
all of those things can
cause workflows to go awry
and for the system to not
behave as you intend.
Ion Stoica: Yeah, and
what about this kind of--
and you mentioned about the
fundamentals still remain,
but again, to be more precise
about concepts like consensus,
consistency, this kind of
distributed scheduling,
which of these concepts kind of
remain more or less the same,
and which are
changing and morphing
in support to support new orbit.
Mark Russinovich:
Yeah. Well, and I think
you know we talk about AI
and running these agent
workloads, and you talk
about the LLMs and
hosting the LLMs.
The things like the consensus
around the infrastructure,
knowing what is
available and online.
Things like load
balancing still matters.
Locality matters still.
So you want to route requests,
especially when you talk
about KV caches,
which is the context.
You need to make sure
that the requests are going
back to the same systems.
Otherwise, you're going to be
wasting compute and bandwidth
as you're moving things around.
So all of those
things still apply.
I think, and this is an
interesting question,
I think, for you.
Are these systems stateless?
Do you consider them
stateless or stateful?
Ion Stoica: I think
it very much depends.
Certainly, because I will also,
I win as a serverless trend.
I think that quite a few
systems become more stateful.
That is because just the trend
of bringing the state in
and saving the state if needed
for the next operation,
in some cases, it's too high.
And it's not only the
state, leading the state
and saving the state,
it's initializing, right?
If you are talking about
initializing the GPUs
and so forth, it can
take a long time.
So this forces you to be
marked more stateful.
The problem with that
is that it complicates,
like we all know,
the fault tolerance.
Mark Russinovich: Yeah.
So when it comes to these
distributed infrastructures
for AI, which include the GPUs,
high bandwidth interconnections,
the KV cache, when you look
at distributed systems
through its evolution,
what assumptions change
with an architecture to support
this kind of computation?
Ion Stoica: So, I think
it very much --great question
-- very much depends on where
you are coming from.
So you're coming from
Spark, it's like big data.
It's about, it's like,
MapReduce plus plus.
It's bulk synchronous
processing, which is a model,
which is a pretty simple model.
You partition the data.
You have stages at every stage.
You have applied the same
task on different partitions
and do a shuffle between them.
What happens with, for instance,
you talk about KV cache
and inference,
things are becoming
so much more coupled,
tightly coupled.
If you think about
mixture of experts
and then you have the KV cache
and you need to distribute it
across different GPUs on the
same node and even across nodes,
then it's things are becoming--
everything becoming
much more coupled
and more difficult
because of that.
Now, if you come from maybe
HPC, maybe you can
say, "I told you so."
Mark Russinovich: Yeah.
Ion Stoica: But even there
I think that with HPC,
it was much more --
you don't have such a . . .
tightly coupling
between the data and, kind of. . .
-- and the compute.
Because even
there, the data was --
you know, you
don't have actually--
in traditional HPC,
you don't have a lot
of data to start with.
Because you do
simulations, right?
And things like that, right?
This was kind of the workload.
So I think that's
kind of what it is.
And this creates a
lot of challenges.
And since even you're talking
about load balancing,
things are changing
so much more quickly
if you think about expert
parallel load balancing.
Because you can change from
layer to layer when you go
in the forward pass to do
the inference to do serving.
And the other thing what
happens, I'll probably talk more
about that, is that things are
evolving so quickly, right?
By the time you build something,
you have new requirements.
It's never ending.
Mark Russinovich: Yeah.
Ion Stoica: Yeah.
So, we have this kind of, I
remember like it was 15 years,
10, 15 years ago when people
started the cloud computing
and so forth, and people are
saying the data center is a
new computer.
I'm just curious right now, is
that kind of abstraction still
of actuality because now you can
have training spanning different
availability zones
and things like that.
I'm curious about that.
Mark Russinovich: I mean,
I think if you take a look
when that statement was made,
it was when a data center
would hold all the compute
that you could imagine in the
data centers at that time.
Even if you take a look
at the evolution of Azure
as a hyperscaler, the
availability zone kind
of became a unit of compute, but
even in an availability zone,
we have multiple data
centers typically.
It's not just one data center
per an availability zone.
Then you have a region, you have
multiple availability zones.
So even for traditional
IT workloads
or serverless computing, your
application can be spread
across many data centers.
And now, you mentioned
distributed training
and AI training, and
that's where you run
into these AI super
factories as we call them,
where you've got massive
datacenters just filled
with GPUs specifically to
host that training workload.
And for that, we passed
the line several years ago
of a single datacenter being
enough to hold the scale
of the AI supercomputers
that we're building now
to train these frontier models.
And then over the last couple
of years, we've crossed a line
of even one region of
datacenters is not big enough
to train these models.
And now we have these
Fairwater systems
that we've launched
these AI super factories
where there are multiple
Fairwaters in Wisconsin,
multiple in Atlanta,
and they're connected
with a dedicated network
so that you can have a
job that spans the GPUs across
both regions with
a very direct cable
between them doing RDMA
across the two regions.
Ion Stoica: Yeah,
it's fascinating.
Now, going back again, like
we discussed a little bit
about serverless, right?
The serverless--
Mark Russinovich: My
favorite services.
Ion Stoica: Yeah. So,
what what does it mean in. . .
this kind of--
when you have today's
long-lived agents,
which can go hours,
sometimes days?
Mark Russinovich: Well, if
you talk about serverless,
it's kind of people speak about
it synonymously with containers.
Serverless equals containers.
And when people
think containers,
they think the original
serverless containers,
which were like Lambda
or Azure Functions,
which are short-lived, and so
people conflate serverless
with short-lived applications
or pieces of code,
when in fact serverless
doesn't have an opinion
about what code runs
in these containers,
and so you could put SQL
Server inside of a container,
and it can run for years.
And it also can be monstrous.
It can have terabytes of memory.
So I think for me,
I separate the two.
And I say serverless
is you don't worry
about the infrastructure, it is
containerized for the most part,
although we talk about
lightweight containers now
and Wasm sandboxes which are
also a form of serverless.
But that's where I
think the whole trend--
if you take a look at Azure's
architectural evolution,
we're moving everything
to serverless.
We're moving the whole
infrastructure to containers
that are on a serverless
infrastructure
that is doing the scheduling
and placement and for the job,
which is expressing constraints.
Ion Stoica: So now
continuing on that note.
We have our infra, we build
these infrastructures mostly
to serve requests initiated
by people directly
or via BI tools and
things like that.
But now we are moving
rapidly to an age of agents,
to having agent loops instead of
just requests as a unit of work.
How does this impact, do you
think, about architecture stack?
Mark Russinovich: Well,
I think we're still
at the early days of this,
actually, because just
in the last few years,
we went from chat
to now agentic systems,
which are this loop
where the agents are
talking to other systems
as part of their computation.
And they might even be
talking to other agents.
And so when it comes to how you
define an agentic application
that consists of these
things, I think we're still
in the early days of specifying
the application model for these.
And a lot of it is, I
think, still ad hoc.
But we're getting towards what
is an agentic application?
What are the components? How do
you place them for efficiency?
How do you automatically deploy
them instead of taking piecemeal
and deploying and connecting
them together after the fact?
So in my opinion, I think
that we're still early.
But I'd be curious to hear
about what you think?
Ion Stoica: So, yeah,
I think we are early.
The one thing I see is that
constant increase in complexity.
Mark Russinovich:
That's for sure.
Ion Stoica: Even the definition
of agents, what is an agent?
Well, was an agent an
LLM invoking a tool?
But now it's much
more than that.
You have a tool, you have an
entire harnessing, right?
Which can be very
complex, right?
So now, and then you are
talking about some kind
of continual learning.
People talk more and more
whether this happens in context,
continuously
evolving the prompt.
And in some cases even
updating the weights, right?
So kind of like RL.
So, and then you have this
kind of, you need something
to support very diverse
and complex. . .
you know, application.
You need to do, for sure,
kind of the inference,
then basically
arbitrary application--
running arbitrary application
because that's part
of the harnessing, right?
And then maybe you are going
also to do some kind of training
if you want to
update the policy.
And so that's kind of things.
And when you have the models, of
course, you can have the models
which is going to be co-located.
It has to be co-located because
if you want to update it,
or it just can be
something running outside,
it can be like OpenAI or like
a new model that's released
by Microsoft.
So that's kind of,
it's so complex.
So you need to think-- to have
something which is very flexible
to support these workloads.
And yeah, I think
that we'll see.
I assume that in time, things
will stabilize one way
or another, but we
are very early.
Mark Russinovich:
Yeah. So one of the things
that I'd be really curious
to hear your thoughts on,
in the systems
that we've designed,
they've largely
been deterministic.
You design the
system, you've got a
workload, you optimize for it.
These systems are inherently
non-deterministic,
as we talked about.
Ion Stoica: Yep.
Mark Russinovich:
And so how does
that change the way
you design a system?
Ion Stoica: That's
a great question.
And just to be clear, it's one
of the reasons they
are non-deterministic
because, obviously, the LLMs
themselves are
non-deterministic.
If you send the same prompt
over and over again,
you shouldn't expect,
or you are not going
to expect the same results.
Actually, in some cases, you
rely on that to get diversity
in order to get
better solutions.
So I think it's like there
are a few things to consider.
One, first of all, what
eventually, what is your output?
And in some cases, like
with coding and so forth,
the artifact can be still
deterministic, right?
You use this to create,
to optimize the system,
to synthesize even a system,
and that one kind of
is deterministic.
You can have harnessing
tests and so forth to check,
and then you can have
metrics to high hill-climb.
If you want to optimize,
optimize for throughput,
for latency.
So the output is still
kind of deterministic.
I think now this doesn't
answer the question
about how you debug your kind
of evolution systems
or agentic system.
And unfortunately, there, it's
like, you have to presumably,
and what you do is, record
the inputs and outputs
and the traces and then try
to replace the traces, right,
to find what the problem
is if there is a problem.
Mark Russinovich: Yeah.
So when you talk about an AI
stack, you talk about GPUs,
network, you talk about
different types of accelerators.
Where do you see the
optimizations happening,
the most important ones?
Or have we reached
some limit someplace
where there's the bottleneck
that we need to focus on?
Ion Stoica: I think
clearly it will happen.
I think there are three. . .
levels of optimizations
will happen.
At the top level, there
will be many algorithmic
optimizations still.
So I assume that a few orders
of magnitude improvement
over the next few years will
come from the algorithms.
What I mean by algorithms, if
you look like, for instance,
just inference or
training, right now,
of course, the workload
changes, you have agents.
You have much larger prompts
or, of course, outputs.
The context, again,
is much larger.
You see a lot of optimizations.
And architectural optimizations,
software architecture, like,
for instance, sparse attention,
different kinds of attention.
You see different layers,
different attentions.
And now you see even within the
same layer different attentions.
Even maybe you'll have per-token
learned attentions
and things like that.
So that's kind of what can
give you a big improvement.
Of course, this comes
with a lot of complexity.
Then, obviously, you are going
to have GPUs, the accelerators,
which are going to
still make progress,
1.5 or 1.6 every
year improvements.
And that's coming, again, with
complexity because it's not
like Moore's law
used to be, right?
The instructions
that architecture is
more or less the same.
How you get these
improvements, a lot of them is
by adding new instructions
which are targeting particularly
new segments of the workload
like I expect you are going to
have more and more instructions
in the GPUs to target this kind
of sophisticated attentions.
And then, from the inherent,
this will go a
little bit slower.
You are still going to
have smaller transistors;
you are going to still
be more power-efficient
for the power per flops will
improve and things like that.
But these are
multiplicative, right?
So when you multiply them,
you can get massive gains
in the next few years.
Mark Russinovich: Okay, I have
another question for you.
Because you've been involved
so much with open source
in AI infrastructure
and analytics,
do you see a canonical
open source-based stack?
And do you think
it will converge
or there will be diversity?
Ion Stoica: I think that
there is some stack
which is used by companies.
There is like-- and, you see--
you have at the lower
level Kubernetes or Slurm.
Under the hood, if you want to
move, because everyone now has
to want to have the freedom
to make a move across regions
or from region to region,
maybe you have something
like SkyPilot.
On top of that, you have to
have some framework like Ray
or Pathways or something
like that, which helps you
to distribute this
kind of AI workloads;
then obviously you have
PyTorch and so forth.
So I think you can put
together this kind of stack,
and then you have vLLM, or
Golang, whatever, TensorRT-LLM
as an inference layer.
And then post-training, you
have kind of WELL or SkyRL,
and things like that, right?
So you can create a stack,
and you have a stack.
I think a pretty good stack.
The question is about what
will happen and how this kind
of stack will evolve because
it's like the one thing
which I see in terms of
complexity increasing is
that we used to build-- one of
the things you teach students,
right, and we learn ourselves
that how do you build
a complex system?
You build this kind of
in a modular way, right?
So you have these components
with nice abstractions,
clean abstractions
which abstract away the
implementation, right?
So then you can evolve each
of them independently.
Now, the problem with that--
and this is when we
are talking about these
layers and all these components,
the problem with that is that,
as we know, it also
comes with some overhead.
And it used to be perfectly
fine to say okay, we are going
to spend a few percent, 10%
overhead had to have this kind
of nice available system,
because at the end of the day,
we can be even faster
because we are going
to evolve these systems,
and the system is going
to evolve quickly and quicker.
But now it's like it's so
much breaking the layering,
and it's called cross-layer
optimizations, right?
It's like, this is what I
see, everything, right?
I don't know, it's
like, in some sense,
it's like all these
layers are going to
get crossed and broken.
And I see, you can do maybe in
an orderly way, but I don't know
where you are stopping.
Is this collaboration
between Ray
and Kubernetes, with you guys?
But what is the thing
here is that something
like Kubernetes wants to
know more information
about the applications from Ray
to make more
intelligent decisions,
something like Ray,
which is up there.
They want now to
have more control
to tell Kubernetes
what to do. Right?
So you can allow that.
But I don't know when you
stop because, of course,
you are no longer going
to have these kind
of clean, narrow abstractions.
I think that's very interesting.
Mark Russinovich:
So, we've got about five
minutes left, I think.
Ion Stoica:
Yeah, so. . .
So, one question
I do have for you,
It's how do you think about--
we are talking about the
workflows, agents, and so forth.
Is that, you think about like
a boundary, two different kind
of patterns of workloads,
or you think are--
Mark Russinovich:
For agents and--
Ion Stoica: And workflows.
Mark Russinovich: And workflows.
Ion Stoica: Traditionally,
what we call them.
Mark Russinovich: You
know, the beauty of agents is
that they can make
workflows dynamically.
And I think that this is,
instead of you having to go
and prescribe a workflow
and write it out,
you can give AI a problem,
and it'll go figure out how
to execute that task and come
up with a workflow dynamically.
When I look at those systems,
if you've got anything
where the workflow is going
to be repeated many times,
you want to make that
deterministic and not rely
on an AI to make it up every
time you've got the problem.
So I think where things
are not well-defined,
where they're very ad hoc,
then AI and agents are great
for making up the workflows
and solving the problem.
But for anything where you've
got a repetitive process,
you should go try to
make it deterministic,
because it's going to
be much more efficient,
much more reliable,
and much cheaper.
So all of those things
are going to be true.
And I think that this is where I
see people over-rotate on, oh,
I can have an agent
go do this thing.
When I'm like, I
look at it and go,
actually you could just
write a simple workflow.
Ion Stoica: You can have the
agent synthesize that workflow.
Mark Russinovich: That's right.
That's right, yeah.
That's the other way to do it
is have the agents make the
workflow, and then the
workflow is deterministic.
Ion Stoica: Yep, that's
what I mentioned about.
Yeah. So the other thing
is that we used to have--
you have training, and you have
serving separate deployments
and things like that.
But now with this kind
of post-training,
starting even earlier on
from reinforcement learning
with human feedback.
And now it's continual
learning and things like that.
It seems that kind of
it's a blur out there.
So what should the
platform look like --
Mark Russinovich:
This is the --
multi-hundred billion
dollar question, isn't it?
I think because we
run into two things.
I mean, you heard about Maia.
Ion Stoica: Yes, of course.
Mark Russinovich: And Maia
is optimized for inference.
Then you hear about NVIDIA's
chips, which are optimized,
for the most part, their
main line for training.
And then you mentioned
like GRP or DRPO or any
of these post-training things
that are happening in the loop
with it, where you're
doing inference
at the same time you're
doing the training.
And so whenever you've got a
situation where you can optimize
for efficiency, obviously,
that's going to be what you want
to do, especially at
the scales you're at,
where you can save
literally tens of millions,
hundreds of millions of
dollars by optimizing
for some specific path.
But when you optimize
for that specific path
and then things change, and
they're not a good fit,
that can be a big problem.
And so it's this tension now
because we haven't even--
like you said, the evolution
of these architectures
hasn't finished.
And so if you over-optimize
for one workload,
you could run into trouble.
So the question is, how general
should we be and leave money
on the table in the short term?
Because in the long term,
we're going to be protected
against changes in
the architecture
or in the application
requirements
versus taking advantage
of optimization now
and potentially being
bitten by it later.
I think that that's the
tension that you see.
Ion Stoica: Absolutely.
Mark Russinovich: Yeah.
Ion Stoica:
Yeah.
Mark Russinovich:
All right. So, we're down to
a couple of minutes left,
according to the clock up here.
So I want to thank
you for coming
and spending time
with us at Build.
Your impact on the industry is
monumental, and it's gracious
of you to come and take
time out of your day
to share your thoughts on the
evolution of AI infrastructure.
Ion Stoica: Yeah, thank you.
And we haven't touched on--
Mark Russinovich:
On Confidential computing.
Ion Stoica: On
confidential computing.
So before going, I know I know
that this is a topic dear
to your heart, Mark.
So can you say something
about like security
governance and so forth?
Mark Russinovich:
Well, absolutely. I mean,
they're all -- from
security governance,
we didn't really get time
to deep dive on this.
But when it comes to jailbreaks
and prompt injections,
I've been doing a lot
of research on this.
This is, like I
mentioned earlier,
a big topic of evolution where
we haven't bottomed out yet.
I think I view it as
kind of the early days
when people were downloading
stuff from the internet
and just your fingers
were crossed.
This is what happens now
when you give agents access
to your company's private
data or your private data
or your access tokens is you're
kind of crossing your fingers
and hoping that things
don't go off the rails
and you end up with a problem.
And we've seen some
high-profile examples just
in the last few months
of people getting burned
by prompt injections.
So I don't think we've come
to the reckoning yet on that
and people
understanding the risk.
And then with
confidential computing,
that is another layer of--
the clock just reset
to five minutes.
So we've got another
five minutes.
[ Laughter ]
Ion Stoica: So now
you can, please.
Mark Russinovich: I think
backstage they liked the answer
so much they wanted
me to continue.
So I can talk a little bit about
confidential computing now,
which is it's independent
of AI, of course,
but related in some ways.
Because if you think about
the sensitivity of the data
that people are processing
with agentic systems,
if it's in a personal
context, you're saying, "Hey,
I really want you to help
me with my medical advice.
I want you to help me
with my financials."
You're giving these agents
so much very personal
and very sensitive
data about yourself.
And if you're in an
enterprise context,
the way you get the value
out of these models
is giving them access
to the sensitive data
of your enterprise.
And especially when you're
hosting this in a cloud platform
or some hoster that's
out of your control,
or even in your own environment,
you want to minimize the
trusted computing base,
the code that has
access to that data,
to the smallest amount possible
where you can have the highest
assurance that it's going
to behave properly and where
bad actors can't get to it.
And confidential computing
is -- now we've got another. . .
It reset again.
I was wondering.
I was like, wow, we burned
through that time really fast.
So now we have 13 minutes left.
[ Laughter ]
So let me just wrap this up.
And I think there were some more
topics that we can discuss.
And maybe we can take some
questions from the audience.
But confidential computing,
for those of you
that aren't familiar with it,
it's hardware-based protection
of data while it's in use.
So the hardware itself
is encrypting memory
and creating a privileged
boundary around the data
such that nothing else on
the system can get access
to what's inside of that
enclave, they're called.
And it comes with a cool
property the hardware provides,
which is an attestation,
where it can measure
what's inside the enclave
and then the application
in that enclave can offer
that attestation to another
system that then can look at it
and say, oh, your compute
inside of an enclave,
I trust that enclave, I
trust your configuration,
I'm going to give you a
secret, typically a key,
which allows you to go and
process that data in the clear.
And it's protected against
so many of the threats
that not having this
enclave protecting
that boundary against.
And when it comes to agents,
having an attestation
of what is the agent?
What is its provenance.?
Do I know that the
data that I'm giving to
the agent is protected
with the highest assurance as
possible inside that enclave?
You're going to see a trend with
AI and confidential computing
that I think is going
to really drive forward
confidential computing.
Confidential GPUs from NVIDIA,
for example, confidential GPUs
from AMD, and even
Microsoft's Maia processor.
Ion Stoica: Yeah,
that's fascinating.
Mark Russinovich: Since we have
more time on the clock now,
which is kind of nice.
Let me go back to some questions
that we skipped earlier for you.
And I guess this is something
we really haven't talked
about is developer experience.
We've been talking a lot
about infrastructure,
but you've got all
this complexity.
When it comes to
developer experience,
there's so many
options out there.
There's GitHub Copilot CLI
there's the SDK,
there's OpenClaw, like what --
and there's doing your own loop,
calling an LLM directly.
We saw Simon Willison doing
this with his own application.
He didn't use any harness.
What's the best approach?
When do you decide, when
do you use one harness
versus a custom orchestrator?
How do you code this,
and how do you measure
what's the best answer?
And in fact, I wrestle with this
too when I'm approaching code.
Ion Stoica: And me as well.
But let me just give. . .
So, I think that. . .
Look, my TLDR is that now
we have, again,
very powerful coding
agents and so forth.
And many of you, I'm sure -- how
many of you use coding agents?
Everyone, right?
I do think that --
actually, the biggest
challenge is that --
and this is --
it's about how do
you know that. . .
the code which is generated
is going to work
correctly for some kind
of definition of
correctness, right?
Is doing what you hope
you want to do, right?
I think that's the key, right?
And the more code it generates,
the harder it is to do
that, right? Because --
-- and I think this
was, you know,
this is also, was true
before, right?
Everyone here probably
developed a production --
-- system, right?
Or, has been involved in
developing a production system.
Where do you spend
most of the time?
You don't spending the
time or most of the time
in prototyping or
writing the code;
you do spend
the time in, kind of,
even, you know, in debugging,
then maintaining the code.
It's easily 10 to 1 effort.
So, in some sense, what these
coding agents are doing
are going to commoditize that
kind of writing the code.
But the bottleneck will be
more and more
in, kind of, verifying.
And, yes, you can
use these agents
to say, "Hey you-- ",
you know,"check
that, is that correct?"
But it's very hard, you know?
Some agents are lazy.
So, without you
understanding the code,
at least at this point
today, I don't think --
and having continuously
having testing it and
enhancing the test,
I don't think you
can trust that code
that is doing what
it's supposed to do.
Because that kind of reward
hacking is very different
from what you can think about.
Let me give you
just one example.
I have so many
examples about that,
but I'm giving you
the simplest one.
You mentioned earlier
about load balancing.
So, say you are
going to say, okay,
I want to develop a load
balancer algorithms
and, you know,
for and -- you know,
using the agents.
And we did that, we have that
a few months ago using EPLB,
right, Expert Parallelism
Load Balancer, of course.
And then what you want to do
is the metrics, you want this,
the load you are
going to handle.
You know, you want
to maximize that load.
Now, one solution is simply,
which we've seen, that
because that's a metric --
the "hill climbs", the load,
is just dropping requests.
Right? Now, you wouldn't think
that when you tell someone,
even when you write the
PRD about the load balancers,
"Hey, you shouldn't
drop the request."
It's that's kind of
understandable, right?
But these models,
they are going to do
that because they are going
to maximize the things you
told them to maximize, right?
In the simplest and
the easiest way.
So that's kind of why
I'm saying it, right?
And there are many things
which you can pass all the
unit tests and so forth.
And then when you look deeper,
there are things which are,
in a way, overfit to your test
you couldn't imagine, right?
It's like that's kind of the
things you still need to,
I think, at this stage.
I don't know what will happen
in a few months, in one year,
but right now, you have
to be able to specify.
If you didn't specify something,
you can almost guarantee
that the systems will
find something around it.
And there are three places
a specification comes from.
So one is, basically --
Actually, there are only two.
And you know, like. . .
One is that the
training data set.
The training data set,
you kind of train,
and some specifications
come from here.
Like, for instance, one year
ago, when you generated code,
you have a lot of
vulnerabilities.
Now, you have fewer
vulnerabilities
when you generate
code with agentic.
Right? And the other
one is from the prompt.
You have to specify what
it should do or not.
If it's not in the
prompt or it's not
in the training data set, it's
going to find a way around.
Mark Russinovich: It'll
fill in the blanks.
Ion Stoica: Yeah, so that's
kind of, I think, that's,
I think, the main bottleneck.
Mark Russinovich: All right.
So, now we really have six
minutes, and I'll give
you a question that I --
that I think is the -- the
question that I get a lot,
and I've got my own
opinion about this,
but I'm curious about yours.
Ion Stoica: So you'll answer
it after I answer it.
Mark Russinovich:
Yeah, I'll answer it.
And this is, I talk to people,
and I explain I've got
so many war stories of
AI going off the rails.
I mean, me and Scott, we
have got this podcast.
I talk about how I basically
sculpt, which I always have.
But even with AI, I'm
watching what it's doing.
I'm control seeing it.
I'm telling it, "That's not
what I want you to do."
And I see it creating this test
or going off in some direction,
filling in the blanks
with something
that is ridiculous or
that I don't want.
And I tell people
this and I say,
you just can't give it a
prompt or a PRD and expect
that you're going to get a
system that works reliably
and efficiently and
does all the things
that you imagine you
would want it to do.
And even if you go and
try to specify it,
you cannot specify it
deeply enough to guarantee
that it's not going to do
things that you don't want.
A lot of what we do is based off
of kind of environmental context
and just kind of the taste
that we've developed.
And so I'm like-- I just don't
see a path to this world where
You don't need engineers that
understand what's going on
and don't know how to guide
the system when
it goes off the rails.
And then, I get this pushback
of, "No, Mark, you're just--"
You know? That's a bet that
I would take with you every day
because it's going to be solved.
Maybe two years from now,
maybe five years from now,
maybe 10 years from now,
the AI will be so good
that you won't need that.
Your example where you
said the load balancer was
dropping requests.
What if you have an adversarial
code reviewer go look
at the system and
say, "You know what,
you shouldn't be
dropping a request."
And it's, is this system
well-behaved? It'll say,
"No, it's not." And so you
just address that.
So where do you lie on this?
Do you think that--
would you be bold enough
to say it's never going to be
solved or do you think we'll get
to the point where
we'll have the ability
to give a specification,
it'll come out great,
and you won't need a human?
Ion Stoica: I think
that in theoretical--
from the theoretical
perspective, it's very hard
for me to see how it's
going to be ever solved.
And fundamentally, because
we know from Gödel
that no axiomatic
system can be complete.
Mark Russinovich: Yeah.
Ion Stoica: So in some sense,
that kind of tells
you something.
I think that when we look at
other techniques to do it,
like for instance, assume that
you have a formal specification.
You can write in Lean,
on Coal, and so forth.
So from that one, if I have
the formal specification,
then you can generate the code,
and then you can
generate the proof
that the code satisfies
the specification.
So that kind of is good,
and you can see that.
The problem is that obviously
then you need to write
that specification, which
is kind of not easy.
And even that when
you write the specification,
it cannot -- you
know, it's like,
if it's incomplete, right?
You don't specify a property
because, you know,
like, in this case,
I write a specification for load
balancers, but I don't write,
"Oh, you shouldn't drop
the packets," right?
So maybe if there is a
conservation law there,
you can argue that
you should put it in.
But there can be
assumptions, right?
Because any
specification, anything,
you have to have
some assumptions,
right, to make the proof.
But you are not going to imagine
all of the assumptions, right?
Mark Russinovich: I got
to -- you know what I think?
You know what is a
full specification?
Actually, programming languages.
Ion Stoica: Almost, almost.
Even that is not.
Let me give you an example --
even that is not.
Mark Russinovich:
Yeah, that's true. But that's --
Ion Stoica: Like, I
remember, you know,
we have this kind
of, I'm not sure really,
like, this peer-to-peer
court system and so forth.
I was young faculty there,
still implementing
all of these things.
And really, really, I
thought it's bulletproof.
And we are testing it on this --
I don't remember, how many
remember about Planet Labs.
Twenty years ago, this
Planet Lab, which is kind
of an infrastructure,
internet infrastructure,
or each organization have these
servers, and then you deploy
at the servers applications,
and then you communicate.
And it breaks.
And I don't know how it breaks.
It has to work.
And when we look about, it
was an assumption we missed,
and the assumption we've
made, implicitly, is a kind
of transient connectivity.
If A communicates with B
and B communicates with C,
then A should communicate
with C. And in the Internet
as a whole, right, because
it's not behind NATs
and so forth, this has to hold.
And it should have hold,
except that is one university
which misconfigured
their servers.
So that blocks some
communication, some traffic.
So that's kind of, I
always think about that.
Mark Russinovich:
Yeah, good example.
Ion Stoica: I couldn't,
you know, it's like,
I was actually, we were
correct about the assumptions.
It should have held, but it
didn't because of a mistake
in the configuration
in the platform.
So that's kind of what
I'm trying to say.
It's extremely hard.
Mark Russinovich: Yeah. So, Now
we are really, I think, at time.
I haven't seen the
clock jump up again.
But it's been a
fun conversation,
a really fun conversation.
And if you like this,
this is the experiment.
It's the first time we've
done something like this.
If you like this, let us know.
So we'll try to do it again.
If you find it boring,
also let us know.
And I think the people
that thought it was boring
probably already
left, so I think--
[ Laughter ]
Ion Stoica: We have a
biased audience here.
Mark Russinovich: But thanks
very much for coming to Build,
and I hope to see
you tomorrow morning
in my Azure Innovation Talk,
where I'll talk a little bit
about some of these things.
[ Applause ]
Ion Stoica: Thank you very much.